hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
von ich laufe gerade so ein bisschen von
meinem haus weg weil da hinten gerade
ein papa und ich habe kein schwert weil
wenn die letzte folge gesehen habt wisst
ihr das kaputt gegangen und ich muss
mich jetzt in meiner spitzer gegend wie
ford kämpfen
ich habe dieser folge leider keine
fragen am start
skelett creeper alles möglich am start
und manchmal meine spitze ist auch schon
kaputt ich muss mich auf jeden fall ein
schwert machen jetzt ich habe kein thema
aber keine fragen von euch am start
allerdings habe ich ein thema am start
und die krippe direkt neben einer bude
alter also ich denke man merkt dass
dieser server auf hart ist alter das ist
ja nicht mehr normal
ich mache jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
ganz kurzen stein schwert und zwar werde
ich in diesem video einfach mal so ein
thema reden aber dass ich eher reden
wollte und zwar den echten wien von
weihnachten so ich mache mir mal eben
hin schwert und zwar wenn euch das ganze
wirklich interessiert wäre jetzt die
ganze folge wahrscheinlich darüber reden
dann würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr
wissen meine dran bleibt als ein thema
ist aber dass man auch viel diskutieren
kann eigentlich müsste ich ja eh wieder
passt glätte töten weil ich ja bei mir
brauche um fichtenholz zu bekommen
um diese setzlinge da wachsen lassen zu
können
die sache ist allerdings ich fange man
zu lange über das thema und nebenbei
versuche ich ein bisschen meinen kleinen
pavillon
wintergarten deluxe ding da fertig zu
stellen acht ach ja ich wollte hier auch
noch hier mit mid mid mid mit dem kies
sondern einen kleinen weg auch noch in
morges jetzt also ein bisschen erde vor
dass das ganze so aus als wird das hier
wirklich so auf dieser erde stehe noch
mal hier noch ein bisschen so 8 der
erste bier schon erwachsen dann fällig
den gleich mal ab obwohl das ereignis
eine position ist wo okay der muss
eigentlich ein kleinerer bomben
ich mache mir jetzt erstmal mit dem
wenigen eisen was ich hier habe da mach
ich mir jetzt erstmal ein paar werkzeuge
damit ich überhaupt mal wieder ein
bisschen aufgestellt wo das eisen schels
am start dann machen wir jetzt noch
ebene eisen spitzhacke und natürlich
noch eine eisenachs womit wir dann erst
mal den baum der abfällen damit wir
genug sachen haben und einen einen einen
einen einen einen ich hab mal zwei eisen
und ich brauche drei für ein halber tag
ich bin auf jeden fall erstmal den baum
ihr ab und zwar der sinn von weihnachten
meine lieben freunde es ist ein thema
das könnte auch irgendeinen redner
irgendwo bei einer vorlesung oder so
darüber reden aber ich sag jetzt euch
jetzt einfach mal was ich zu denke wie
weihnachten für mich ist es ein bisschen
thema
naja zum sprechen darüber ich lass mich
ja sehr oft gerne ablenken und viele mal
noch oft konkrete du kannst ja gar nicht
kommentieren lässt sich ablenken
versucht ihr mal zu zocken und euch auf
sachen zu konzentrieren und dann
nebenbei dann einfach noch über ein
thema zu reden über das man sich noch
keine vielen gedanken gemacht hat
das ist schon recht schwer und ich denke
ich werde hier erstmal noch wo die tür
hin kommt so ein anderes holz seen
packen und zwar dass hier also man muss
sich da auf jeden fall bei konzentrieren
und ich versuche es einfach ich weiß
nicht ob ich schaffe aber für mich ist
der sinn von weihnachten nicht der der
zurzeit immer in den medien und zu
verkörpert wird weil in den medien mit
weihnachten nach dem motto kauf zu viel
ihr könnt wir haben ganz viel in unseren
geschäften unglaublicher weihnachts
rabatt bei dem man dem unternehmen
unglaublich hier unglaublich da finde
ich es überhaupt nicht weihnachten
ich finde eigentlich wirklich er
weihnachten hat etwas mit der liebe tun
und das mal aufeinander dieser krater
die scheiße aus dass man aufeinander
acht gibt und so was alles und nicht so
viel mit diesen ganzen geschenken und
zwar denke ich mir geschenke kann man
sich die ganze zeit kaufen aber
weihnachten hat was mit teilen und so zu
tun und wenn man sich dann was schenkt
vor allem an dem geburtstag von jesus
christus also von einer anderen person
in dem christentum zumindest dann weiß
ich nicht dann ist es halt keine ahnung
das ist genauso wie ihre mutter hat
geburtstag und wenn man schenkt sich so
selber was wünscht sich selber was dazu
also ich weiß nicht was das ganze soll
und was es bringt weihnachten ist
einfach so verankert dass man ja ich
weiss jemand telefoniert den geburtstag
von jesus christus und dann vergisst man
so komplett diese ganzen wesentlichen
dinge die jesus einem quasi eigentlich
so gelehrt hat also ich bin die ich gehe
nicht sehr oft in die kirche
ich bin auch nicht so der große kirchen
befürworter ich hatte eigentlich die
kirche das muss ich mal so sagen ich bin
allerdings gläubig also ich glaube an
gott aber ich glaube nicht eine kirche
weil die kirche ist für mich ein verein
von geldgeilen leuten und das hat jetzt
nichts damit zu tun dass ich sage dass
es gotteslästerung oder irgendwie sowas
sondern es gibt eine ganz klare linie
zwischen kirche und religion und zwar
kann man auch an gott glauben immer
nicht an die kirche glaubt finde ich und
von daher ist es für mich so dass jetzt
natürlich mein bett abgebaut aber naja
für mich ist es halt so ich glaube zwar
an jesus christus und an den lieben gott
und alles mögliche was damit verbunden
nicht oder verbunden werden mag aber
einfach nicht an die kirche weil die
kirche mit aktionen wie ablassbriefe
hexenverbrennungen und anderen dingen
einfach weil sie nicht ist für mich zu
einem wirtschaftsunternehmen geworden
weil ich glaube die kirche hat die
meisten aktien auf der welt an
irgendwelchen unternehmen oder so also
ich bin letztlich sowohl bei sicher aber
ich denke dass ich glaube so was hab ich
mal gelesen irgendwo und das ist schon
extrem krass wie sich diese kirche
einfach entwickelt hat finde ich so was
muss nicht sein und deswegen finde ich
auch dass dieses bild was von den medien
gemacht wird immer nicht auch nicht
sogar alles von wahlen
und zwar sollte wirklich darauf berufen
werden dass bei diesem letzten abendmahl
und dann wenn jesus gestorben ist und
alles mögliche jesus hat halt immer
relativ viel
das ist jetzt eine religionsschule luca
der tat immer so wissen der welt wasser
zu wein gemacht und hat halt leuten
geholfen und hat leuten das augenlicht
wieder gegeben und keine ahnung was wir
damals noch in der schule hatten aber
ich finde halt einem weihnachten soll es
echt zu sein man soll mit der familie
beisammensein von mir aus dem letztes
mal soll das ganze zelebrieren aber
nicht nicht mal weihnachten kriegt man
ja meistens sogar also ich habe damals
immer zu weihnachten von vom geldbetrag
hier höhere geschenke bekommen als zum
geburtstag und das verstehe ich nicht
und ich will es auch nicht verstehen
dass weihnachten so krass was mit
geschenken und marketing zu tun hat das
finde ich echt nicht gut und ich wollte
jetzt erst mal eine kiste noch ein
stückchen größer machen also ich weiß
nicht was ich von dieser ganzen
weihnacht sache erhalten sondern für
mich ist wirklich dieser wahre sinn der
weihnacht von weihnachten ist halt
einfach dass man das mit der familie
verbringt das man beisammen ist dass man
sich wiedersieht liebe freude eierkuchen
so was in die richtung dass es so meinen
meinen wunschdenken von von von
weihnachten
aber ich denke eigentlich habe das ganz
gut auf den punkt gebracht das ist jetzt
ein thema aber das mal geredet habe bei
so etwas immer so ich hatte fünf fragen
am start und sieht auch in zukunft
wieder sein aber auf die bin ich halt
immer recht kurz eingegangen
und jetzt wollte ich auf jeden fall mal
so ein bisschen einmal kurz länger über
sowas reden ich denke ihr wisst was ich
meine vielleicht schreibt mir dazu
einfach eure meinung in die kommentare
weil mich auf jeden fall eure meinung
immer interessiert ich lese immer
fleißig mit und kommentiere auch selber
fleißig in den kommentaren
wenn die leute ihre meinung schreiben
oder allgemeinen ihre meinung hierzu dem
projekt oder zu irgendwas einfach
beschreiben weil durch seinen like den
sieht man zwar aber der
er sagt halt nicht okay ich bin die
person geleitet oder sowas sondern
derzeit einfach nur da hat jemand gleich
das ist natürlich auch schön aber da
kann man sich nicht mit drauf
unterhalten auf dieser basis sieht man
jetzt erstmal eine neue schaukel hier
mit den eisernen die ich wieder dabei
mit den eisen die ich hier habe und mit
den sticks den ich hier habe so da mach
ich mir hier eine eine schaufel eben
dann habe ich nur zu fressen und dann
ich weiß halt echt nicht was ich hier
hin bauen soll
ich denke da passt irgendwas weißes hin
irgendwie weiß wofür wolle oder oder ich
weiß ich weiß echt nicht dass sie tot
extreme kaka aus irgendwie ich weiß
nicht was ich hier noch hin bauen sollte
ich denke hier kommen auf jeden fall
voll sonne tür sollte ich sage einfach
alles doppelt dich folio case fall
einfach komplett raus der wahrscheinlich
fällt aber der komplette inhalt direkt
vor meine füße oder so erst mal hier
alles in die kiste jetzt einsortieren
ich denke einfach dass ich hier so eine
tür hin bauen werde wo ich dadurch gehen
kann
aber so eine auch ich weiß ich habe so
einen winter da sind kleine tür bauen
soll oder ob ich sondern acht komme ich
habe hier nur noch zwei tore macht hier
natürlich eine richtige türen und auf
dem boden wieder das tolle andere holz
ja ich weiß echt nicht was ich da hin
machen soll
ich denke dass hier werde ich so zu
bauen und ich werde hier sondern so
einen tunnel vielleicht hin bauen so ein
bisschen auch aussprache den bergen
kripo ein bisschen auch aus schnee das
heißt ich glaube ist erstmal nach davon
und hole mir da so ein bisschen schnee
dass ich da
nee ich lauf noch da ganz hinten aber
diese richtigen schnee blöcke das sehr
viel geiler jedenfalls werde ich mir
davon dann einfach so ein paar
schneeflocken machen und dann sonne nie
clou schnee tunnel bauen wie ich das mit
dem iglu schon gemacht habe und dann
geht dieser schnee quasi einerseits ist
es in meine farming höhle da unten die
eigentlich gar nicht so richtig farming
höhle darstellt jetzt riesig und es geht
halt trotzdem zum teil auch noch in
meinen wintergarten der dann da noch
gebaut wird
alle diese diese schnee teil in der du
musst einmal drauf hauen du hast einfach
direkt abgebaut ist das richtig neues na
ja ich nehme hier auf jeden fall ein
bisschen schnee mit ich hoffe dass ich
mit dem thema irgendwie nicht jetzt
irgendwelche nerven euch getroffen oder
so es gibt ja oft leute die sache für
mich ist dass weihnachten ganz anderen
sinn aber deswegen ist das halt hier das
ist freie meinungsäußerung ich hab das
jetzt einfach mal so gesagt wie ich
finde wie es ist ich meine es gibt
locker auch leute vom marketing in
irgendeinem unternehmen die sagen
weihnachten müssen wir ausnutzen da
kaufen viele leute was ich meine stimmt
ja viele leute kaufen was aber für mich
ist es halt einfach falsch zu
weihnachten klar am geburtstag obwohl
alle feste die ich sag mal bieten die
man nicht selbst bestimmen konnte sind
keine richtigen feste also dass jemand
geboren wurde das kann man natürlich
feiern
aber ich finde man sollte nicht die
person da habe ich mir letzten schon
gedanken gemacht sollte nicht die person
die geboren wurde das geschenke bekommen
gefeiert werden sondern die person die
diese person zur welt gebracht hat also
die mutter sollte da geschenke bekommen
aber das sind total gesellschaftliche
maße gesellschaftliche ideale die jetzt
hier von mir angezweifelt werden darum
sage ich gar nicht gehen sondern es soll
um den wahren sinn von von minecraft
aids bin ich aber auch daraus hier
wieder eine wahre sinn von minecraft ist
auf jeden fall dass ich mehr als 16
gerade hier am start up und jetzt
einfach schnell wieder zurück laufen
muss möchte auf jeden fall so ein
bisschen von dem tunnel noch mal eben
hinbauen ich weiß wir sind jetzt bei 11
minuten oder so aber ich muss halt heute
noch diese ganzen sachen hochladen weil
wahrscheinlich wenn ihr das video gerade
seht bin ich unterwegs wo ich bin ist
eigentlich erst mal echt egal ich moment
mal dieses skelett hier unten damit ich
so ein bisschen wo sind die knochen da
es dennoch und einfach damit ich hier
vorne diese bäume jetzt mal an
mit zombie spanier wieder am start ich
nehme euch allen auf großteil selbst war
und mich auch aus gesehen freunde durch
einfach jeden windelweich geprügelt ihr
seht schon ihr barbara bruder hier der
nächste und wo ist das skelett wo es als
glück da hat das kind er das skelett
trifft mich eh nicht das trifft mich eh
nicht und warm und farmen und dann ist
das geld auch noch tot an das pferd da
hinten kommen das verbraucht denn schon
fährt es fährt fusion beider jockey es
ist wahr ich drehe ich treffe immer
spyder job des letztes in der folge
vielleicht könnt euch dran erinnern
nicht recht einfach 22 ad hoc ist direkt
hintereinander
der terminator einfach nur eisen schwert
in der hand und jetzt kommt hier auch
noch welche england mehr zu krassen
schwierigkeit normales hier sind einfach
so viele zombies am start und alles zu
viel im monster allgemein ich muss jetzt
einfach mal ganz kurz zurück jetzt ist
auch noch schon wieder eine spinne ich
will einfach nur jetzt hier leben
braucht dies direkt gewachsen
begeistert sind und jetzt auch hier eben
die spinne weg schlachten dann setzen
wir hier noch den baum dann ist er auch
fällig kommen perfekt ausgenutzt hier
wieder
ich will einfach nicht dass im krieg bei
mir wieder aus steht letztlich etwas ein
paar fackeln hin dass hier auf jeden
fall in der region um ein haus herum
nichts sport so da oben sind schon
fackeln hier okay okay okay da unten
sich auch wieder ein skelett am start
ich denke ich mach das provisorisch
erstmal hierzu und hier kommt jetzt
dieser tunnel in meine nase ob des todes
und zwar meine ich einfach dass ich
jetzt hier das ganze so ein bisschen so
um platziere also ich hier einfach du
dann kleinen aber feinen tunnel weg mit
schnee mache wo man durchlaufen kann und
dann kommt man letztendlich hier in
sonne treppenbereich rein und dann kann
man hier macht es für mich erst mal so
ein bisschen zu dass ich auch hier so
erhalten natürlich hier ja das ist
natürlich ganz flink über den blog hier
unter uns ab und das können wir jetzt
gar nicht mehr doch können wir doch noch
und zwar hier um die ecke so hier nach
dem blog abgebaut und jetzt machen wir
hier so eine wendeltreppe nur damit ihr
wisst wie das ganze dann aussehen soll
hier kommt dann auch seinen eingang
von der seite so rein und das ganze wird
hier natürlich auch an die landschaft
ein bisschen angepasst dass wir hier
natürlich dann geht es nicht wie meine
nase gerade juckt das kann nicht sein
was da los ist und man auch schon wieder
so rothmann ich bin ich werde einfach
krank ich werde einfach wieder krank
freunde das ist aber dass ich so in dem
im winter da wird man halt nun mal krank
aber ich finde eigentlich ganz cool
glaube ich wenn das hier so ist wieso
eine lawine so ein bisschen so als wenn
das hier so alles so eingekracht wer ein
bisschen chaotisch hier so um die ecke
hier noch ein bisschen schnee liegt hier
so alles ein bisschen rum da oben ist
noch ein bisschen schnee drauf ihr so
als wenn ihr so eine lawine irgendwie
eingestürzt wäre sieht glaube ich ganz
cool aus da kommt hier auf jeden fall
auch erstmal noch eine fackel dran und
da geht dann meinen weg nach unten
als wäre das eine lawine irgendwie
eingestürzt und hat schon dass wir jetzt
noch einen gegner oder so uns als würde
ich sagen meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat würde ich mich über
eine positive bewertung freuen wie steht
ihr zum thema was ist der wirkliche sinn
von weihnachten und dann würde ich sagen
sehen uns in der nächsten folge
minecraft fries wieder morgen wenn ich
wieder zurück bin in alter frische und
dann für dich